hello welcome back to game sports
coverage of game of the Year 2015 we've
already talked about those stinkin
consoles playstation 4 xbox one and Wii
U I keep reading these articles about PC
culture taking over America the personal
computer guys oh that we all love it
right it's here to stay it's here to
stay I'm a warrior for PC yeah I'm a
warrior from a pc to its ok i built a pc
2 months ago oh yeah and i feel like i
built a pc nine months too late all the
great games that came out this year on
consoles witcher 3 wild hunt metal gear
solid the phantom pain even games like
rocket League better on pc is that fair
to say it's not only better but not now
all these people are all these arguments
that you have about exclusives in which
which console is better you have access
to all literally almost every game there
are very few non pc exclusive when
people talk about exclusive they mean
console exclusives everybody gets I
don't can see the order 1886 stuff but
heard about yeah in fact you're gonna
get tomb raider before anyone on the
PlayStation 4 knows we're gonna come out
in a couple months but to be fair and
we're gonna play those games on a PC and
have them look better you got a shell
out maybe four or five times the amount
of money you would spend I know people
are gonna jump in this term actually
four five hundred others yeah but really
yeah in order to compete on a
technological performance level for a pc
you have to spend more money but that
said oh man do games look good on
high-end PC yeah i can look better for
for a medium call for a moderate cost
you can get something that is comparable
to what you're getting on console them
yeah and you have to have a pc like it's
it's something that you are going to
have in your house and it's been
heartbreaking lucky when i was playing
to witcher 3 on xbox one and i loved it
and it was a great experience in my xbox
one but i couldn't even look at like
footage of it on the pc because i was
like man that's literally twice as many
frames look super super ready and the
mods and all that like the things
they're gonna extend the life of those
games like that's gonna be on pc maybe
you might get something like that on ps4
or on xbox one or on the console but
piscine like that's built in that's part
of the culture of it yeah let's talk
about some stuff then that you wouldn't
necessarily get on consoles that you
would only get on pc a game to kim at
couple of weeks ago started off
starcraft blizzard they make
pc games and starcraft legacy avoid all
finished up now wrapped up nice and
sweet and hired a storm as well of
course this year a lobby people playing
at that as well and good experiences to
play on PC Justin it is and we're going
to be getting more starcraft I mean it
felt like this was the end this is the
end of that specific trilogy and now we
have Nova covert ops which is going to
be an extinction of starcraft not quite
where we thought a starcraft was going
when they announced this hit at blizzcon
but i mean this is just one of those
examples of an experience that you're
basically only going to get on pc
Blizzard always serves their pc audience
so well and we they do poor things over
to console overwatch is something that's
going to be on literally everything yes
but on a game that's been fantastic fun
to play on PC I almost wish it came out
officially so I could stick it in my top
ten games in the air like we've played
it does size of our game it's fantastic
but strategy games are just a great
example of something that it doesn't
work as well on console both because
it's so much reading because it requires
such a fine tune a type of controlling
strategy games are always gonna be at
home on PC and that's both the best way
to play them in the most enjoyable when
you try to do them on constable it never
works as well what I was trying to
callate like a list of games that came
out on this I kept running into the same
frequent problem over and over again
which is that there are so many games
coming on pc now which aren't really
coming out there like in out far they've
been coming out forever like unreal
tourneys a game I played a bunch of this
year are not still in alpha dirt rally
is a game that's a great one you were
playing for loads of its basically
outright cuz you can purchase on early
access and I think now it's just out but
for a longest time I'm like oh I am
playing this game almost daily if it's
in development and I'm helping give
feedback on it and it's amazing and to
you guys as point it's like that's the
one thing that the pc has that the
console doesn't there's no one man
there's no Phil Spencer there's know
like this is gonna be I there's no gate
keeper there's game new uh yeah there's
a duel but you need the mask I have to
go through him yeah like you can promise
something independent yeah also you
and you can kick-start something right
and it's gonna be available when you
want it on that but so it's like it's
great that we can talk about it as its
platform but it's not like it's so open
and that's what and that's what gives
you the power because it's like also I
want to get a monitor that runs at 140
frames per second you can't do that one
console why would you get a monitor the
runs that fast on a pc i'm gonna be
playing games at that speed i want to be
playing dirt rally at 100 frames per
second whereas force is locked at 60
it's like they they had to do all their
magic just to get it to sixth like where
i was in your hands yeah the powers my
hands like oh well I guess I'll get a
better graphics card that just came out
because I can do that now I'm running so
it's like I don't know there's just so
much more flexibility that but to play
devil's advocate went when you do have
that much freedom you're also given the
freedom to have really shitty
experiences that are shitty and broken
for a really long time thank you don't
have a gatekeeper making sure the
quality meats a certain threshold is a
disaster on PC ministry that was
promised remains it's still yeah still a
basically just refund but like PC on the
other side as well it's it's scalable
you've got those big triple-a
experiences also some really guys indie
games kamesh this year as well first
story early in the air undertale more
recently as well i mean there's so many
games that wouldn't exist on console
because you have to have that gave you
because somebody has to be making money
but when you're just making a game like
well i'm going to put this out there on
steam see if i make money i've been
working on it for a couple years in my
basement like Pierre mollified but not
to belittle the work that they do but
there's a lower threshold to having a
success and bugger but there is a
barrier sorry to interrupt you but the
refund system and steam now negates that
problem the other thing is well like I
saw outside of this sort of like general
you know release schedule these are the
games coming out when you look about
what where you know exciting things are
happening in pc gaming you look at these
sports it's continuing growth you look
at like streaming that it's continuing
growth like almost all of the stuff
that's on twitch is pc games csgo league
of legends DOTA almost all of the big
eSports tournaments up our system parts
apart from perhaps the finding any
community is all pc like that's where
it's happening I feel like now more than
ever in this weird way when
kids are on YouTube and watching twitch
and they're going to buy something they
don't want to buy a console they want to
do super see whatever else is doing on
PC well it's surprising i have a nephew
who loves to watch minecraft stuff mmm
what system does he want what platform
does he want you want so we you oh
really yeah so it's all over the place
yeah I mean I think actually 22 contrary
to your point a little bit I think kids
are actually growing more comfortable
experiencing games passively than they
are actually interacting with them hmm
and I think that that is going to keep
consoles within their grasp because
their parents can buy for them well look
it the other nice thing about pc is like
as much as kind of i feel like we're at
the top end we are the ones who are
gonna get a really high powered graphics
card and we want games to look as
amazing as they can but pc is accessible
to everybody even if you have a lower
end graphics card something that maybe
cost fifty dollars or a hundred dollars
you can still run so many games and have
access to these games well companies
have been trying to you know break that
chestnut for a couple of years now when
it comes to like making oh here's the
console equivalent of a pc and of course
steam machines we thought perhaps this
was the year where that could break
through Peter doesn't really look Nick
necessarily that's been the case well
the pc market doesn't necessarily want
those things and someone coming from a
console background looks at okay there
are five steam machines in front of me
oh wait there are four configurations of
each one of those which one do I pick I
don't know I mean they it's sort of
navigating murky waters at that point
you don't know what you're getting and
what is actually a good value and then
what games you can run perhaps more than
steam machines i think cloud streaming
is going to be the thing that will allow
people with cheaper pcs to really get
into pc gaming nvidia really has been
doing some great stuff with that I
played some stuff using the Nvidia
shield that was running on a server like
states away I was playing street fighter
4 and it wasn't perfect I'll tell you
what a couple seconds later or a couple
minutes after playing I started to get
used to the delay and if you think about
a game that's not a fighting game right
like so many other games work well in
that context and a really high in
experiences so the PCs like steam
machine represents an effort to minimize
the cost associated with PC gambia and
make it more approachable I think cloud
gaming is really going to be the thing
that does that but that hasn't kicked
off yet and in 2016 we're all sort of
waiting for the you know more we've
already seen the Samsung gear VR and hit
store shelves next year we're looking
forward to a lot more obviously have so
playstation 4 your i'll be coming out as
well oculus the leaders in this space
coming ash when we're already seeing
that the consoles are struggling when it
comes to graphical capability surely if
we're looking at the future of you are
looking at that exciting new frontier
the pc is where it's going to be
happening and we're going to see that
gulf continue to widen like this is a
just like xbox 360 and ps3 those were 10
basically seven-year consoles this is
supposed to be a decade-long console pc
is just going to keep getting stronger
and stronger and able to handle things
like oculus able to handle extra things
that we're throwing at it then consoles
aren't going to be able to keep up with
that I think the the type of VR that
we're talking about is important here
though because so many people imagine VR
as you know they take it literally right
boys engine a full body suit that I plug
into that likes I'm talking about the
content right like people who people
really imagine VR as like this oh my god
like everything around me looks so real
hmm but I can tell you firsthand some of
the low 5er stuff is still immersive
because your movements are still
connected to it so I think in that
regard yes the pc will will explore like
the really impressive stuff but it's not
going to totally own vr i'm not
convinced of that yet and even then when
oculus comes out in the spring you know
who's going to shell out the cash for
that it's going to be the hardcore but
the hardcore the few does not dictate
what games are created right it's the
mainstream the mainstream doesn't pick
up on it we're not going to see those
experiences everyone's hoping for it's
gonna be the smaller stuff that drives
it forward a great year for the PCs a
great year for video games in 2015 and
some of the best video game event in
2015 looked pretty fantastic on the pc
so gotta say it's been a great year for
the personal computer and also in terms
of exclusives they got one coming early
next year XCOM 2 but they always have
exclusive mean looking like this year's
kerbal space program yeah like Dhoni
just use an early Isis forever yeah yeah
then 2016 is gonna have those same kind
of titles things that you just wouldn't
it be able to play on a console or you
just wouldn't expect like because
someone's gonna come out with it like oh
I've been working on this for a couple
years yeah here it is now check out my
awesome game loads more to look forward
to I just computer honey thank you so
much for coming on and talking about PC
culture with me and thanks to you for
watching our game of the year coverage
so far add to watch all of our all
platform reports make sure you go back
on to our game of the year hub on
gangster calm and say due to gamespot to
find out what our game of the area's
some of our favorite games across the
breadth of video game consoles and the
pc itself
you